my name is flughafen meine damen und
herren vor einigen monaten habe ich
bereits ein video hochgeladen in dem ich
ein google spiel gespielt habe hellrotes
ihnen wo ich kenne keine einzige von der
endspiel geht es darum dass einem die
website einen kurzen satz vorgibt und
man selbst muss ich dann quasi in die
lage von google hineinversetzen und
sicher überlegen wie google das ganze
auto kompletten würde ich hab das
kugelspiel bisher einige mal auf einem
kanal gespielt allerdings immer nur auf
englisch und jetzt ist vor einigen
wochen die deutsche version davon
rausgekommen und bevor ich ihn noch
langsamer würde ich sagen fangen wir
direkt mit dem ersten satz also hier
steht eine kleine und wir müssen jetzt
hier reinschreiben was wir denken was
google vorschlagen würde ich würde sagen
eine kleine tube dosen
wie bin ich auf die chance bekommen
mundharmonika schreibe ich meine ich
weiß auch nicht wie ich darauf komme es
ist falsch
jetzt habe ich noch zwei versuche eine
kleine spende vielleicht nee das ist
auch falsch und dann schreibe ich noch
eine kleine was was zu googelt man denn
wenn man eine kleine ein gemüse und
nachtmusik spinne spinne text okay wir
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten satz
der satz der uns diesmal vorgegeben wird
ist das ende von das heißt ich schreib
mal das ende von der welt eventuell nee
das ist auf jeden fall schon mal falsch
im das ende von dem film vielleicht
näher das ende von film einfach nur es
war wieder alles falsch
darauf hätte ich auch noch kommen können
wir sind immer noch bei null punkten aus
zwei runden das heißt ich wieder auf
weiter im der satz ist wer ist meine
mutter schreibe ich einfach wenn mutter
schon auf platz zwei ist dann würde ich
jetzt auch mal großmutter eingeben
das ist falsch wäre es meine oma gebe
ich immer noch einige dass es auch
falsch habe noch einen versuch wäre es
meine freundin also wir hatten mutter
großmutter und freunden
es muss eine weibliche person sein also
wäre es meine tante vielleicht neben
großcousine nicht die schwägerin mama ok
walter als nächstes haben wir hier als
vorgabe was kostet eine ich würde sagen
was kostet eine dose bier nee das ist
schon mal falsch was kostet eine massage
vielleicht nicht das ist falsch
was kostet eine jet
was kostet eine zahnbehandlung schreibe
ich mir noch ich denke jetzt mal richtig
bescheuert was kostet eine scheidung
hochzeit beerdigung ich denke irgendwie
zu kompliziert also beim nächsten satz
den namens wie schmeckt eine muss ich
auf jeden fall ein bisschen dünner
denken wie schmeckt eine zahnbelag
falsch suppe schmeckt eine aids ich habe
absolut keine avocados ist noch alles
voll mit früchten also papayas drachen
früchte mango zigarette steht hier
zigarre aubergine kokosnuss aber gut wir
machen weiter mit der nächsten runde
nachname von mir ne nachname von
das waren auch wieder total blöd
vielleicht noch nachname von freunden
annehmen weil es bei einer hochzeit ja
eigentlich üblich ist es auch falsch
und dann noch nachname von ich weiß es
nicht ich hab ich habe absolut keine
ahnung nachname von tieren je nach name
von jesus eine ahnung wir machen aber
auf jeden fall weiter mit dem nächsten
satz nein danke
auf englisch das halt wenn das keiner
sucht nein danke dafür will auch nicht
nein danke dir vielleicht nein da
englisch
nur weil ich den richtigen satz ich
schreibe also runde acht haben auch
wieder null punkte zusammen sammeln
können einem rauchen ist tödlich
schreibe ich jetzt einfach mal okay okay
das sind die nächsten 100 punkte rauchen
ist gefährlich schreibe ich jetzt noch
mal mehr rauchen ist verboten nein und
rauchen ist illegal schreibe ich noch
mehr rauchen ist gesund um gesund das
neue sind rauchen ist das neue sitzen
allerdings meine damen und herren nun
auch schon zu zehnten und somit auch ein
letzten runde des heutigen videos und
zwar ist der satz du bist mein schatz
platzecks du bist mein verlust nee du
bist mein freund nähe was gebe ich dir
jetzt als letztes ein du bist mein ein
und alles schreibe ich mal noch wir
haben also bisher ist schatz und ein und
alles richtig das heißt es ist richtig
romantisch
du bist mein herz und meine seele
das ist das ist falsch aber hey hast
dich opladen also ich konnte jetzt in
zehn runden in denen man insgesamt
maximal hätte 5.500 punkte sammeln
können
410 punkte verbuchen
an der stelle wird das heute wieder ist
alex auch beenden beide lieben freunde
wenn euch mal wieder luca spiel google
hier diesmal auf deutsch gefallen oder
das unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter
dem video da schreibt mir uns in die
kommentare ob ich das wetter noch mal
spielen soll und abonniert main kanal
falls ihr noch kein teil der luxus sein
[Musik]